these men training on a football pitch
in eastern Ukraine say they want to
defend their country from Russian
aggression
pricor has its origin in German
nationalist groups of the 18th and 19th
century
and the leaders of the group say it has
thousands of members but only 60 have
bought their own licensed weapons and
regularly serve alongside Ukrainian army
soldiers on the 420 kilometer front line
24 year old glebs studied Homeland
Security and crisis management at
University he says one day he wants to
open a gun shop why did you choose
because there are more ideologically
closer to me
so I decided to join them
would you say they are more
ideologically closer to you can you tell
me what you mean by that how
what do you believe in ideologically
can we pause that okay sure
by core is not the only armed group
accused of being neo-nazis that has
appeared in Ukraine since the conflict
with russian-backed separatists started
in 2014.
others like these men with the powerful
as of Battalion have been incorporated
into the Ukrainian Security Services
Under the ministry of interior
freikor and many groups like them have
been praised by ukrainians for their
willingness to take up arms and defend
the country against what they describe
as Russian aggression
but that does not mean that they are
popular amongst voters at The Ballot Box
the Coalition of right-wing groups only
managed to win less than three percent
of the vote in the last parliamentary
elections in 2019
but some of its leaders such as dimitro
Yarosh have been made advisers to the
head of the Ukrainian military
participants in this torch-lit rally
resembling Nazi gatherings in 1930s
Germany hold a banner honoring Stefan
Bandera a Ukrainian Nazi collaborator
widely recognized as organizing the
massacre of tens of thousands of ethnic
poles in Ukraine towards the end of
World War II
Bandera is the nickname fellow freikor
volunteers gave this man 24 year old
bondan says the group has its origin in
what he calls pan slavism connecting
similar-minded people across Slavic
regions of Eastern Europe including
Russia
yeah but that changed when the conflict
started
if the West respects democracy and
pluralism of views they have to respect
our views but to get a political future
we would need to show people we can be
competent leaders we need to gather
like-minded thinkers qualified and
educated people if we manage that we
will have a political future and
political strength
experts say the far right in Ukraine has
its origins in football hooliganism
poverty and a country that along with
many other post-soviet states has
struggled with political corruption the
Russian Ukrainian border didn't really
exist for these movements the Russian
far right and the Ukrainian far right
moved in these same circles and then
when the war came some of them chose one
side and some of them chose the other
and the fact is that the connections are
still very much there in some parts and
it's almost certain that there are
Russian agents of some sort Within These
movements
Franklin leaders say they've been
overwhelmed by people wanting to join
since the crisis between Ukraine and
Russia has escalated
but as NATO countries throw their weight
behind Ukraine they should perhaps be
aware of what this conflict is creating
on both sides Charles Stratford Al
Jazeera kharkiv eastern Ukraine